what you're looking at is the actual
side projects directory on my computer
none of these side projects have gone on
to become the next Facebook yet but I
have not failed I've just found hundreds
of apps that don't work if you're a
developer entrepreneur it's extremely
important not to over engineer things
Andy jassy once said invention requires
two things one the ability to try lots
of experiments and two not having to
live with the collateral damage of
failed experiments in today's video
we'll build a full stack chat app using
pocket base and svelte then deploy it to
a Linux server on the Node for just five
dollars I call this the Spock stack and
prepare to be amazed at how quickly it
can get things done stupidly I made this
demo public so you can actually try it
out on the internet right now this is
not my first rodeo and I know you guys
will spam it with the most horrific
comments imaginable but this time
messages can be moderated with Community
reactions if a comment gets pooped on
five times it disappears from the UI the
back end magic behind this application
is a relatively new tool called pocket
base which is like a free and open
source Firebase written and go that
provides user authentication along with
a real-time database powered by SQL Lite
but unlike any other base out there it
compiles everything to a single
executable and that means to self-host
it all you need is one little server
which costs less than your Grande soy
milk macchiato Simplicity is the
ultimate sophistication but today we'll
find out if the Simplicity of pocket
base can actually scale to kick things
off we're going to start things in
Reverse by deploying pocket base to a
Linux server in the cloud luckily for us
lenode has sponsored this video which
means I get to Make It Rain with a
hundred dollars in free credits for
everyone watching this video for those
that don't know lenode is one of the
original cloud providers that's been
around since 2003. their platform is a
perfect fit for this project because
like spelled and pocketbase it's famous
for Simplicity unlike big cloud
providers you can get a Linux server up
and running with a few clicks with flat
predictable pricing that won't cause
collateral damage later after you
register go to the dashboard and click
the button to create a new node then
choose an image with your preferred
Linux distro I'm going going with Debian
but the real Chads out there will use
Arch by the way then choose a region and
the size of your machine and finally
give it a password and click create Step
One is complete we now have a Linux
server running in the cloud I told you
that would be easy let's go ahead and
make a note of its IP address to access
it on the internet now in Step 2 let's
deploy pocket base to it first download
and unzip pocket base from the website
I'm also using Debian on my local
machine so we'll download the Linux
version unzip it to get this single
pocket base executable you can run it
locally by running pocket based serve
but I want to run it in the cloud on my
lenode server so I can access it from
anywhere just like a platform like
Firebase let's open up the terminal and
use secure shell to access the lenode IP
address as a root user it'll require the
password you created earlier and now we
have access to the Mainframe we're
currently in the root directory so let's
go ahead and create another directory
called PB and now we just need to upload
the pocket base executable to this
directory we could do it with rsync or
an application like filezilla but I
think the easiest approach is to use
secure copy which will simply copy the
local file over to the remote directory
we just created run this command from a
separate terminal on your local machine
once that's done we can go back to the
terminal on the lenode machine and run
the pocket-based serve command and to
make it accessible over the Internet
we'll use the HTTP flag followed by our
IP address and Port 80. congratulations
you just self-hosted your own back end
that you can now access over HTTP with
the IP address it serves a rest API as
well as an admin dashboard that you can
access with the underscore URL however
there's a few more things I want to show
you to make it fully production ready
the first thing I would do is bring my
domain over to lenode it has a fully
featured DNS manager and pocketbase uses
let's encrypt to automatically generate
an SSL certificate to serve your backend
over https all you have to do is add
this extra flag to the serve command now
the next thing I would consider doing is
mounting a volume to the PB data
directory this is where pocketbase
stores all of your data a volume is just
its own file system that can be moved
around to different servers on node we
can easily attach an extra 20 Gigabytes
for Just Two Dollars and then finally I
would recommend setting up a systemd
service to automatically restart pocket
base whenever the server reboots and now
it's time for step 3 where we model the
data for our chat app navigate to your
pocket-based dashboard and create an
admin user from here we can go to the
database and by default it has a
collection for users these are the users
of your application which contain Fields
like username email password and so on
what we need is a way to create a
one-to-many relationship between users
and chat messages create a second
collection called messages and give it
two Fields the first field is text for
the message content itself and you can
add some optional server-side
validations here like Min length and max
length while the second field user
creates a relationship that says a
message belongs to a user under the hood
pocketbase creates a foreign key for the
user ID on the messages table in the
sqlite database go ahead and click
create to update the schema and now you
should be able to create new records in
the database the that takes care of our
data modeling now let's make it secure
every collection in Pocket base can have
API rules these rules determine who can
access your data from a front-end
application by default the messages
collection can only be accessed by admin
users however we want anybody to be able
to view the messages so let's go ahead
and hit the unlock button for list and
view users also need the ability to
create new messages but it's critical
that they only create messages
Associated to their own user ID we can
enforce that rule by ensuring that the
user property is equal to the request
auth user ID and just like that we've
eliminated tons of complexity that we
would need in our backend code otherwise
save the changes then head over to the
users collection for users we already
have a bunch of rules built in but we
want to give users the ability to view
each other's profiles so let's go ahead
and remove the rules for View and list
to make this data public now that we're
somewhat secure we can start building
out the front end with svelte as you may
know I use spell to build the fireship i
o website but it's also been used by the
pocket-based developers to build their
admin and UI as well it's a great fit
for this project because it's really
good at building real-time uis thanks to
its built-in reactive stores generate a
new project with Veet then select the
spelled option and we'll also go with
typescript open the project run npm
install then npm run Dev to serve it
locally then in the code delete all the
boilerplate and create a new file called
pocket base in the lib directory
whenever building a new app I usually
start by thinking about user
authentication what we'll do in this
file is provide a way to listen to that
current user in real time from anywhere
in the application to handle that we'll
install the pocket-based JavaScript SDK
with npm Once installed we can then
import it in this file as well as
writable from svelt store now to connect
to our backend all we have to do is
initialize pocket base with the URL it's
hosted at which in this case would be
the lenode IP address from there I'm
creating a variable for current user
that's equal to a writable store its
default value is the pocket base off
store model which is equal to null when
the user is not logged in n or equal to
the database record of the currently
logged in user that contains Fields like
the user ID username and so on now the
value of this model will change when the
user signs in and signs out and we can
listen to those changes by registering a
callback for the on change event when
this event fires we can update the
spelled store with the current model
that gives us a way to subscribe to the
current user let's put it to use by
creating a login.spel component inside
this component we'll log in a user with
email and password what's awesome about
that store we just created is that we
can subscribe to the current value
anywhere in the application reactively
by putting a dollar sign in front of it
for example we might say if current user
render the text signed in as current
user dot username now the question
becomes how do we sign in a user well
let's start by creating variables for
username and password then create an
HTML form that has two inputs for those
values and it's felt we can easily bind
the variable to the form value with the
bind value directive now we can access
the current form value in our script
let's create an async function called
login that awaits a call to the
pocket-based collection of users then
calls the auth with password method
using the username and password as
arguments and that's all the code it
takes to authenticate a user however we
don't have a user yet which means we'll
also need another function named sign
out and this function we'll set up some
initial data for a new user like the
username password and we could also pass
a name and email address here as well or
whatever custom Fields you configured in
Pocket base we can then take that data
and create a new record in the users
collection once created we call login
with that same user data and that's all
it takes to sign up but it'd be a good
idea to wrap this in a try catch block
and render an error message if a bad
username or password is used we also
need a sign out function which is
accomplished by calling auth store clear
now let's go into the HTML and bind
these functions to buttons which is
accomplished and spelled with on click
and as one final touch I'm also going to
listen to the on submit event on the
form and prove prevent the default
action so it doesn't refresh the page
when submitted now let's open the
app.spel file and declare the login
component there if we view the app in
the browser we should now see this login
form and when you enter a username and
password and click sign up the UI should
automatically re-render to show the
current user's username and now we're
finally ready to build the fun part the
real-time chat messages feature let's go
ahead and create a new component called
messages we can import the on Mount and
on destroyed lifecycle hooks from
spelled as well as pocket base our first
goal here is to fetch the most recent
messages which we can represent
initially as an empty array from there
we can fetch the messages when the
component is first initialized with on
Mount and this code will run once at the
beginning of the component lifecycle to
make a query to the messages collection
use get list to fetch a paginated list
of messages that starts on page 1 and
has 50 messages per page it also takes
an object where you can do things like
sort and filter the query in our case we
want it sorted by that created field
what's really cool though is how easy it
is to join in relational data remember
every message has a user field that
points to a user record if we want to
also include the user data on every
message we can do that with the expand
option and that means we get all the
data we need without any complex SQL
joins now the return value is a result
list and we can set our messages array
as the result list items from there we
can go into our HTML and loop over the
messages with a spelled each block
notice how for each message I have the
message ID in parentheses this creates a
keyed Loop so svelte can keep track of
all the items in the list to render them
more efficiently for each message I'm
going to render out the message text in
the database and also because we join in
the user I'm going to render out the
user's username and also generate a
unique avatar for each user using an
awesome little service called dicepair
let's go ahead and try it out in the
browser I also have the pocket based
admin UI side by side and as you can see
here it fetches all the messages from
the database that's pretty cool but how
do we create a new message message let's
go back into the code and set up a
variable for a new message then Define a
function called send message for a data
we'll need the text of the new message
and also that current user's user ID
remember we can always get that by
putting a dollar sign in front of it
because spelled is awesome and now we
just tell pocketbase to create a new
message let's go ahead and take this
function and bind it to the on submit
event on a form that also prevents the
default action and binds the value of
the text to that new message variable
let's go ahead and open it up in the
browser again and try to create a new
message as you can see here it creates a
new message but we need to refresh the
entire page to actually see the message
and that's not going to fly for a
real-time chat app the final thing we'll
do here is make these messages update in
real time let's go back into the on
Mount callback and then we'll call
pocket base collection messages and
subscribe to the entire collection with
the star symbol this allows us to run a
callback anytime a message is created
updated or deleted the action tells us
what happened in our case we want to
update the UI if a new message was
created or deleted when created we can
update the messages array with that new
record one caveat with real time though
is that it won't include that expanded
user record although we can easily fetch
it with a get one query if needed then
for the delete action we can filter out
the ID of the message that was removed
that gives us a real-time listener but
whenever working with real time it's a
good practice to unsubscribe when the
data is no longer needed because
otherwise you could end up with memory
leaks and unnecessary reads on the
database create a variable to represent
a function named unsubscribe we obtain
this function from pocketbase when
making the call to subscribe once we
have that function as state we can then
call it on the on Destroy lifecycle hook
to end the subscription when the user
logs out or if they navigate to a
different page let's open up the browser
and try it out you should now have a
chat application that updates the
messages feed in real time and now we
can run npm build to build our site for
production and deploy it somewhere on
the internet in fact because we have a
single page application we could
actually do this online node by
uploading the generated files to a
storage bucket then configuring it as a
static website host the final thing you
want to know is that as your website
grows pocketbase will need to scale
vertically with more CPU and RAM to
handle more and more traffic this can be
easily accomplished by simply resizing
your lanode a bigger server can handle
more traffic it can easily handle tens
of thousands of concurrent users and
should be more than adequate for the
vast majority of projects out there this
allows you to fail over and over again
as a developer without a bunch of wasted
time and money as collateral damage
thanks for watching and I will see you
in the next one